If you've implemented
app indexing,
you're getting all the
benefits of new users clicking
on app pages and installing
your app from search results,
as well as your current
users returning to your app
again and again.
But once you're there, how
do you know how you're doing?
You could, of course, enlist
your coworkers, your friends,
or your family to do
searches on their phones
and see if deep links
from your app show up.
But wouldn't it be
nice if you could
track where your app shows up
in search results, for which
queries, which content from
your app is most popular,
or if there are any
technical issues?
There is a better way.
My name is Mariya,
and I'll show you
how to use the new
reports of Search Console
to get deep insights
on how to optimize
your app's performance
in search results
and get found on Google.
By the way, if you haven't
yet implemented app indexing
and you want to
know how to do that,
check out the developer site.
It has the most
detailed information.
Back to Google Search Console.
It's a free tool
that shows you how
Google understands and treats
your content in search results.
In fact, it's the best place
to look for top query, top app
page data, as well as for app
indexing and technical issues.
To be clear, Google
Search Console
is different from analytics.
If you imagine the
process of search
with the click as
the middle point,
analytics typically
focuses on how
the user is behaving
after they click--
what are they doing inside your
app, what are they clicking on,
how often they click, and so
forth-- whereas Google Search
Console focuses on what happens
before someone enters your app.
Specifically, if you've
implemented app indexing,
Search Console will
provide you a ton
of data about how users
are searching for, finding,
and navigating to
content inside your app.
It can even show
you the times when
your app showed up in search
but no one clicked on it.
So let's take a
quick look at how
to use Search Console to improve
your app's discoverability.
We'll use a recipe
app as an example.
It's got a bunch of pages
which are already indexed.
Are you ready?
Let's go.
Search Console shows a lot
of very comprehensive data
about your app, so we don't
just show it to anyone.
No, no, no.
You need to verify that you
are the owner of the app first.
It's simple.
You just need to enter Search
Console using your Google Play
account and add
the app from there.
The Google Play account
is necessary to prove
you really do own the app.
Now we can see
the app dashboard.
It might take a day or two
before your app's data appears,
and in the meantime,
what you can do
is connect your app to your
website inside Search Console.
Associating your
site to your app
is necessary for app
indexing to work.
Plus, it helps with
understanding and ranking
the app content better.
So now that we've finally
got our data, let's see,
what can we do with it?
Remember earlier when we
were doing random queries
on our phone trying to see
if a deep link was triggered?
Let's look at how to
do that the smart way.
The first and most
important thing
you can find out
from Search Console,
how well is your
app doing in search?
For a recipe app,
how can we find out
which are the most
popular dishes?
Every app developer has specific
business goals, a target
audience, and success metrics
to keep track of regularly.
For our recipe app, we want
to increase the user base
and get more regular users.
We're primarily targeting
English speaking users
on their phone in the kitchen
looking for something to cook.
Who's actually searching for
and finding content in your app?
You can find out where
the users are from,
what devices they're using,
and what they're looking for.
The search analytics
report in Search Console
has all of this info.
In search analytics,
you can immediately
see the top queries for
which your app pages show.
There are also options to
filter by specific queries,
by country, or by app page.
For our recipe app, we recently
added a lot of salad recipes.
So let's see if any
of them are actually
showing up for salad queries.
You can add filters to
highlight only a type of query--
for example, queries
containing the word "salad."
In our case, we're
getting very few clicks
for salad-related queries
for the past month.
Is this because they
don't show up in search?
Let's see.
You can add impressions
as an additional metric,
so you can compare
how many people
saw a deep link versus how
many actually clicked on it.
Hm.
It looks like salads are not
as popular as we thought.
App pages from our recipe app
get decent impressions but very
few clicks for
salad-related queries.
What is popular then?
If you sort by
clickthrough rate,
you find the most
convertible queries.
Summer desserts.
Our app shows up a lot
for summer dessert queries
like fresh berry cake
and peach cheesecake,
and people are clicking through.
In this case, it
might be a good idea
to beef up the desserts
section of our app.
Now, let's see which are
our most popular recipes.
You can do this from
the Top Pages filter.
Here again, it's useful to
compare your expectations--
which pages do you consider
most important-- with the ones
that people actually
search for and click on.
If there is very
little overlap, you
may need to restructure
your navigation,
or make the most important
content easier to find.
Another thing to consider is,
have you provided deep links
to all of your app pages?
If we encounter errors while
indexing your app content,
we won't be able to show deep
links for those app pages
and search results.
So it's important to keep track
of new errors in Search Console
and debug the underlying cause.
Here is our Crawl Errors report.
You can find the type
and the number of errors
we've detected.
Turns out our recipe
app has two types
of errors, content mismatch
and back button behavior.
That's why app
deep links were not
showing up in search results.
Content mismatch means
that the app content
is too different
from the content
of the corresponding web page.
As for the back
button behavior, we
want to make sure people are
not trapped and can get back
to the search results.
You can investigate
specific error types
to see a list of sample
pages with that problem.
Let's take one of the content
mismatch errors from our recipe
app to see how to debug it.
Each example app page show
its corresponding web page,
the dates when we last
crawled both, also
step-by-step instructions on
how to fix the specific error.
For content mismatch
errors, it's
really useful to see
your app page the way
Google sees it to
understand where
the mismatch is coming from.
Try the Fetch as Google feature.
Compare the rendered result
with the corresponding web page,
and see what you need to fix.
In our case, it seems to be
a pop-up window asking users
to sign in or create a profile,
which makes the render app page
content appear very different
from the web page content.
Removing that fixes the
content mismatch issue.
Mystery solved.
We took care of the
app indexing errors,
and our app pages are beginning
to show up in search results.
So now you know how to use
Search Console to monitor
your app for errors, and improve
your app's visibility in search
results.
To get started on analyzing and
troubleshooting your own app,
add it to Search Console now.
If you want to know
more about app indexing,
check out our developer
site in your next video.
And don't forget to try
out the delicious lava cake
recipe in our app.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]